se inició el pasado 24 de diciembre fue
uno de los primeros países de américa
latina en iniciar la vacunación cuando
llegaron las primeras dosis de la vacuna
facer sin embargo la llegada masiva de
estos cuatro millones de dosis en esta
semana a los que se sumarán unas dosis
parecidas en la primera quincena de
febrero permitirá al gobierno iniciar la
vacunación en la población más
vulnerable con el objetivo de lograr el
ambicioso plan de vacunar a 5 millones
de la población más más vulnerable al
kobe en los tres primeros meses desde
2021 y 15 millones de chilenos en los
seis primeros meses de este año ahora
patricia pero no toda la población
chilena está a gusto con las vacunas de
procedencia china le pregunto cuál es la
polémica en torno a este tema
así es esta semana saltaba la polémica
cuando uno de los sindicatos de
trabajadores de la red privada del
hospital de temuco en el sur del país
afirmaba que a ellos se les había
prometido que se iban a inocular con la
vacuna de facer que es la que conocen y
que la que es aquella que les da más
seguridad y que por lo tanto no querían
ser vacunados con la vacuna china esto
ha generado muchísima polémica el
colegio médico del propio de la propia
región de temuco ha salido diciendo que
se vacunar a la población con la vacuna
que esté disponible y el director del
instituto de salud pública respondía a
estos funcionarios afirmando que puede
enviar toda la información disponible en
formación que han solicitado otros
países para implementar esta vacuna que
es una vacuna completamente es segura y
qué
se utiliza un virus inactivado que no
hay ningún riesgo y que estos
comentarios responden por tanto a otros
objetivos y a otros fines sin embargo lo
mostrado por los funcionarios del
hospital de temuco responde también un
poco a la preocupación que existe en una
parte de la población chilena que no ve
con tan buenos ojos la vacuna china como
ve por ejemplo la vacuna de facer o la
de oxford que también fue aprobada esta
semana en el país
patricia como siempre gracias por toda
la información desde santiago la capital